♪ ♪
>> Harold: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS CONSIDERING A
NATIONWIDE LAND ON A NEW GAS
STOVES CITING HARMFUL POLLUTION
RELEASE THAT CAN CAUSE HEALTH
AND RESPIRATORY CHALLENGES, ONE
STUDY FOUND IT WAS A CAUSE OF
12% OF CHILDHOOD ASTHMA CASES IN
THE U.S., BUT THERE IS IT FIERCE
BACKLASH COMING GAS STOVES EARLY
IN 40% OF AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS
AND DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN IS COOKING
UP SOME OUTRAGE THAT THIS IS A
RECIPE FOR DISASTER, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS NO BUSINESS
TELLING AMERICAN FAMILIES HOW TO
COOK THEIR DINNER.
I GO TO MY COLLEAGUE HERE TO MY
RIGHT, JUDGE, YOU SEEM TO BE
GOING WITH THAT COMMENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: ABSOLUTELY,
NOBODY IS GOING TO TELL ME THAT
I CAN'T COOK WITH THE GAS, ANY
GOOD COOK COOKS WITH GAS, IT'S
AN IMMEDIATE UP DOWN, LOW, HIGH,
AND I TRY TO COOK WITH ELECTRIC
STOVE IN FLORIDA, I KNOW, AND
WHAT I DID, FIRST OF ALL IT'S
THE ULTIMATE NANNY STATE THAT
SAYS YOU CAN'T DRINK 32 OUNCES
OF SODA DRINK IS NOT GOOD FOR
YOU, WHO ARE YOU TO TELL ME
THAT?
I DON'T NEED YOU TO TELL ME
THAT, AND THE OTHER THING IS,
WHY DOES EVERYTHING HAVE TO BE
REGULATED?
YOU WANT TO COME INTO MY
KITCHEN, AND WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO NOW?
ARE YOU GOING TO LIKE KNOCK THE
DOORS DOWN TO SEE IF I REALLY
HAVE A GAS STOVE?
AND BY THE WAY, THE ELECTRIC
STOVES ARE MORE EXPENSIVE IF YOU
WANT TO HAVE ONE, AND THEN TO
COOK ON IT, THE ELECTRICITY IS
SO MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE, SO ALL
THE WAY AROUND I THINK IT'S
RIDICULOUS THEM BY THE WAY, BUT
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, IT'S ABOUT OUR
HEALTH, I WILL TAKE CARE OF MY,
THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: WHEN DID YOU COOK IN
FLORIDA?
DOUBLE GOAL?
>> Harold: WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS?
>> Jesse: THIS IS AN ATTACK ON
NATURAL GAS, NOT GAS STOVES, THE
ROCKY MOUNT INSTITUTE, BUT IF
THEY DO?
TRYING TO TRANSFORM THE GLOBAL
ENERGY SYSTEM TO A SECURE,
CLEAN, PROSPEROUS IS THE BLUES
ZERO CARBON, IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
ASTHMA, THEY JUST PUT THAT IN
THERE, IT'S ABOUT GETTING RID OF
NATURAL GAS.
FOLLOW THE MONEY, HAROLD.
>> Harold: AS YOU FOLLOW THE
MONEY, YOU COME UP.
>> Dana: ELECTRIC STOVES ARE A
LOT MORE LIKELY TO HAVE HOUSE
FIRES AND GAS RANGES, AND THE
DEATH RATE IS 3.5% HIGHER
WITHOUT.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOU RATHER
HAVE ASTHMA OR DIET?
>> Dana: THIS COMES OUT ON THE
SAME DAY THAT WE FIND OUT THE
OZONE LAYER IS LIKE NOT A
PROBLEM, SO PEOPLE LIKE AT THE
ROCKY MOUNT ANSWERS YOU WANT YOU
TO LIVE IN CONSTANT FEAR OF
CLIMATE CHANGE, BECAUSE IT FUNDS
THEIR CITIES AND THEIR
LIFESTYLE.
>> Harold: THAT'S AN
EXCLAMATION MARK, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT THIS?
>> Greg: THE DOVE IS BAD FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT, BUT MY TOASTER
IS RACIST, HAVE YOU CHECKED THE
RATINGS?
IT IS CLEAR OF BLACK TOAST IS
WRONG, AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
NICE SHADE, IT'S JUST DISGUSTING
EVERY TIME I WALK INTO MY
KITCHEN, THAT TOASTER IS JUST
DEEPLY OFFENDING ME, AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO, BUT IT IS JUST
LIKE, WOMEN AND MINORITIES ARE
HURT HARDEST BY RACIST TOASTERS,
THAT'S THE HEADLINE IN THE NEAR
TIMES, HERE'S THE SECRET,
EVERYTHING IN LIFE IS BAD FOR
YOU.
YOU CAN DIE FROM DRINKING TOO
MUCH WATER, IT'S CALLED
DROWNING.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT WAS
GOOD.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Harold: BEFORE THEY BANNED
THIS SHOULD THINK ABOUT GETTING
VENTILATION IN THERE.
>> Dana: THEY ARE DOING IT IN
NEW YORK CIT